president Trump's early-morning tweet
canceling the meeting with the Taliban
surprised many including the Afghan
government but it has actually welcomed
the decision the main goal of our peace
roadmap is is a ceasefire and a direct
negotiation with the Taliban so these
two components are very important
the Taliban refuses to talk directly
with the Afghan government which it
regards as illegitimate and corrupt but
it did agree to negotiate with the u.s.
whose forces invaded Afghanistan 18
years ago after the 9/11 attacks on
America
there have been nine rounds of talk
since October last year but during that
time Taliban fighters have carried out
numerous attacks and suicide bombings
and America has also continued its air
campaign which has hit the Taliban but
this year has also caused the biggest
number of civilian casualties the latest
Taliban bombing was in Kabul last
Thursday in which 12 people were killed
including an American soldier two days
later the US president in a tweet
ditched what he said was going to be a
secret meeting at Camp David
even as the Taliban was claiming
responsibility for Thursday's attack
zelma Khalilzad the u.s. chief
negotiator was on his way to Qatar for
further talks that were later described
as positive but the Afghan government
said the talks gave the Taliban
recognition the Taliban has responded
angrily to trump canceling the talks in
a statement released on its website they
said the agreement was finalized on
Saturday both sides agree to all points
they talked about intra Afghan talks to
begin on September the 23rd but warned
that their struggle will continue and
the US would suffer more the US has been
criticized for offering the Taliban too
much and the raising fears that the
country could descend into civil war
once the bulk of American forces
withdraw if there is no agreement
between the Taliban in the United States
the government about the travel of the
foreign foreign forces from Afghanistan
that will be the very first situation
not only for Afghanistan that will be
the very worst situation for the region
in the international community and that
is something that troubles many Afghans
we know the Taliban is not trustworthy
if they do whatever they want and they
misuse Islamic laws in a terrifying way
this country won't be better with them
and the government we are afraid if the
Taliban come out not only will women's
rights be violated but also all human
rights all sides appear to agree that
militarily there can be no winner in
this conflict but also achieving a
lasting peace is not going to be easy
either
where this leaves the peace process is
anyone's guess it depends largely in
what the Taliban chooses to do next
either escalate the violence or return
to the negotiating table in a different
frame of mind Afghanistan waits to see
which one it will be Tony Berta Lee al
Jazeera
Kabul